I like Samuel Leeds here and on this
video I'm going to be giving you three
things that you need to consider when
buying a property to rent a serviced
accommodation so stay tuned so right now
we are in Litchfield city center which
is close to where I live and also we do
have property in Litchfield as well now
when you look into the rent out of
property for serviced accommodation
purposes there's three things that you
need to consider and look for number one
is that the property is in the right
kind of area there is a market for
serviced accommodation in that area now
it doesn't have to be on a beach it
doesn't have to be in a touristy area
particularly a city center whereby there
are jobs there are people will usually
work for serviced accommodation
Litchfield works great I think the best
place in the UK is Edinburgh followed by
I think it's Oxford and then Cambridge
so is there a demand for it you can
speak to companies like we always speak
to a company called a VEVO they rent out
our service accommodation they put us on
booking.com they put us on Airbnb
they'll also give you an idea of of the
demands and of the market where luckily
I've got a really good relationship with
a VEVO which is fantastic so that's
number one market number two is
accessibility the property needs to be
in an area and a position and the layout
of the house needs to be such a way
whereby you can systemize it whereby
there's no hmm manager need it please do
not be one of those people that have to
go and let your guests in because that
is just completely ludicrous you need a
key safe outside the house and that
needs to be like I'll give you an
example I had loads of apartment and I
was thinking they'd work so well as
service accommodation but the key safe
couldn't be outside the property because
it was in a public high street and it
would have just looked really out of
place and public people were walking
past and it just wouldn't have worked
but one of my students actually told me
Lesley
whose amazing said to me Samuel why
don't you just rent a local car park and
put the key safe in the carpark I was
like genius that tip alone is making me
thousands of pounds a month but it's
really important to make sure that you
have accessibility accessibility into
the property which is system art about
rhm our manager or any kind of manager
also that the room
himself are self-contained so the second
thing once you've got the area it needs
to be the right kind of house with the
right layout with the right
accessibility and then thirdly once
you've got the right kind of property
you've got the right area you need to
make sure that when you're buying a
service accommodation property or even
doing as a rent to rent that you have
permission so you need permission from
the lease if it's an apartment you need
to make sure that the leasehold does not
forbid you from renting out a serviced
accommodation if it does there are
sometimes things you can do to work
around it you can try and talk to the
the owner and persuade them and use you
know your your magic words you can use
shorthold ast contracts so what you can
do is you can rent the property of all
the apartment to a company and you own
the company and then the company does it
as a you know a service accommodation
but I really would recommend there are
things you can do you can be creative
but always put your cards on the table
and make sure that what you're doing is
legal and aboveboard you're also going
to need permission from your mortgage
company your mortgage lender if you're
buying a property to rent out a serviced
accommodation you need to be upfront
about that because there is a different
type of mortgage that you would need so
those are the three things that I would
say consider if you are looking at
buying a property to do a serviced
accommodation hope that's helpful see
you next time thank you so much for
watching if you benefited from that
video please do share it with your
family and friends for more videos like
it you can watch right here and if you'd
like to spend two days with me at the
property investors crash course watch
this video see what happens but whatever
you do don't forget to subscribe right
here and I'll see you next time